so maybe you can talk about the training
like feeling yourself during training as
well
is there and also as part of that is it
possible to train
mostly fasted because as a side comment
let me just say i like again not
anywhere not even like one tenth of your
level of performance but you know i
i try to push myself and i just feel
much better when i'm fasted so
water and maybe some salt for longer
runs for anything over like 10
15 miles but not no food yeah i think i
mean i like to train on empty stomach
uh i do most of my my biggest training
session usually in the morning and
it usually will determine whether i eat
something not before that is like how
much do i need to eat that day in order
to stay on top of it to build training
again the next day
so i'll i'll usually do something
similar to what i do before a race if i
need to kind of stay on top of calories
for the day so i'm not like
at noon with like no calorie intake and
like 5 000 calories to try to consume
before i go to bed that night and get
out and do the same thing the next day
uh but yeah i think uh in in if i were
if i were doing what you're doing
like if that were my lifestyle i think i
would do almost all my runs fasted
i don't see why i would be eating a lot
before it because it's like
um i'm just introducing something that
could
especially if you're noticing like
here's what i'd say if i was doing that
and i was like wow this run sucks and
then i introduced something beforehand
and now my run was feeling great my
progress was getting better
that's when i would maybe consider
having something before but if you're
running both of those
those like self experiments you're
noticing yeah if i eat something before
i go on this workout
the workout's less enjoyable i'm not
noticing any any
increased improvements on it again it's
a little messy like we said before it's
hard to really you can't go back and try
it a different way on that specific day
but i think i think most people if
they're just like if they go at it with
like
no bias in the sense that they're like
trying to make one work versus the other
you can get at least a good enough look
at it and if
absolute peak performance in one
activity one
very specific activity isn't your goal
then it's like
do you really care if one x has a two
percent performance increase
that you won't even probably notice
because there's other variables that
will clearly overpower that two percent
one way or the other and there's some
benefit in terms of freedom
and letting go of like having to think
about some of these variables
i see sort of fasting is even if it's
like a
hit on the performance it's worth it to
just not think about it
there's some really nice aspect to just
putting on shoes
not caring like what shorts you wear or
like what your outfit is like not being
optimal in every way just not caring and
just enjoying the
purity of just running yeah no matter
what
and just enjoying the natural aspect
yeah there's a side to me that sometimes
just like
craves a lifestyle where it's like i
have like such a small
house and only what i need and just like
a handful of food products that i know i
enjoy and work well for me and i don't
even have the distraction of the other
stuff
there's like a there's like a there's
almost like a weight that comes off your
shoulders when you can when you think
even just thinking about it like it's so
simple so the reason i i'm mostly a
minimalist like that the reason i have
stuff is i realize like
you probably have to fit into society
and if you want to have
other people in your life you should
probably get used to having stuff yeah
because because most people like stuff
right yeah well yeah there's that side
of it too and
there's there's a whole you don't want
to ostracize yourself too
much and i think anything you can kind
of like you can
manipulate that a little bit where
there's things that are like not
specific to uh you know that's gonna
negatively impact the people around you
or your
experiences with them so there's a
balance like everything i guess
you